[Laughter]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night it's New Year's Eve Eve
you know and this is actually our last
live stream of 2022 New Year's Eve Eve
yeah okay like tomorrow night is next
and then Sunday is New Year's Day it's
tomorrow's Friday right no today is
Friday today is Friday tomorrow's
Saturday tomorrow is Saturday so we're
going out tomorrow to go do this do the
club
well yeah you said okay
I mean I don't know yeah so this
tomorrow's New Year's tomorrow's New
Year's Eve yeah okay tomorrow night is
okay
yeah we'll go
okay we'll either uh which one do you
want to go to because
there's two yeah they're having as far
as I know they're doing Memento Mori at
Barbarella yeah which will probably be
less of a [ __ ] show because it's not how
many people are going to that that we
know I don't know okay I don't know I
haven't checked we'll have to check
or we can do mannequins which like I
said that's gonna be a [ __ ] is which is
going to be
um I mean you saw it at Halloween
it's gonna be like that worse like you
couldn't move it yeah and also um I like
I said I think they're doing the
blackout fetish thing so it'll be like
super dark in there and it'll be able to
be half naked so it'll be that so
everybody is Gonna Come it is probably
it is closer a little bit a little bit
although you know
uh you know they're both about to be
honest even though Barbarella is farther
it's easier to get to because you can
yeah you can take the toll road the
whole way instead of to me surface
stream to me it's the same okay
um
I don't know we'll see who's going where
we'll see how it is
we have to see where the cool people are
doing yeah of course
I don't know yeah I didn't know if you
wanted to go out tonight but then you
went to the biker bar so I assumed you
didn't want to go out tonight because
you already went to the biker bar no I'm
[ __ ] up so that's but I could go I
could go tonight well I'm not ready
though because that's what I mean that's
why see I gotta I can't just no I could
go I can't just go with the drop of a
hat you know what I mean I got
preparations I gotta make you know what
I mean yeah you don't have hair or
makeup or anything like that you don't
have to do anything like that you can
just throw on a shirt and boots and
pants and you're ready to go I can't do
that
you know we'll we'll go tomorrow yeah if
that's if that's if that's what you want
I mean I don't know you'll you'll if you
want to go tonight I mean we'll no I
don't I don't actually I don't okay if
you don't want to go then don't worry
about it well like I said I don't see I
don't have no money anyway so it's like
I got money I got all kinds of money a
couple more money than God no you don't
yeah
if you did I wouldn't have it yeah right
I'm just kind of thinking I don't know I
just kind of feel like mannequins would
be fun but then on the other hand it
would probably be like a [ __ ] show
because it's going to be Amateur hour
whereas Barbarella will be better
because it'll be like more exclusive
because it's not in the middle of
everywhere yeah I just don't know where
everybody's going and that's the
difference it will be cheaper if we go
to Barbarella because I don't drink as
much there yeah because they don't have
right like cocktails and I don't care
because it's fun at [ __ ] mannequins
well it depends but the thing is it'll
probably be so packed we won't be able
to do anything that's what I'm saying
it'll be like Halloween which Halloween
was fun but it's like you couldn't
really you couldn't do anything you
couldn't really do anything like you'd
get there and then like you just I think
we I we just stood mostly in one place
all night because you couldn't go any
place right every place was like so
crowded yeah so how's everybody doing
let's see who let's see who's in we got
Zach and Graham's in Grandpa's hammer
everybody's here yeah
um
John Smith
Tom Sykes
Tammy's here what's up Tammy John Smith
says if you can leave the house in under
10 minutes you probably shouldn't leave
the house
for guys though I'm just saying like you
know what I mean and especially guys
that you know don't have any hair
like you
I'm not [ __ ] with you I'm just no I'm
just saying that you it's just easier
it's like lower maintenance if I looked
good bald I would totally shave my hand
because it's like that's a [ __ ]
ordeal I don't [ __ ] need yeah you
know what I mean
but I don't I don't look good with ball
with I don't know I don't look good when
they're here I was at the [ __ ] I was
at the Oasis which is [ __ ] local
biker boy yeah and I was talking to this
uh old lady she's like well I used to
call her an old lady she's like she was
67. I guess that is an old lady that but
yeah it's an oldish yeah she's more than
10 years older than me
and she's telling me how pretty I am so
I started showing [ __ ] photographs
the way I used to look
[Laughter]
when you look like Rick Springfield
she was such a pretty boy
yeah I showed her [ __ ] uh just like
10 years ago when I had or not even 10.
a few years back when I had hair and
everything before the beard she was like
and before I before getting this jacked
and [ __ ] people don't recognize me
yeah I don't look like that anymore well
I mean you've changed a lot to you it's
not just you know it's not just you like
working out and stuff it's also you
being bald and having a beard and a
mustache which you've never had before
yeah they don't even recognize me so
like that's you that's like three things
that are different yeah
foreign
1992 hi Jenny and Tom love your podcast
well thank you very much welcome uh hey
Dave Dave is here hey happy almost 2023.
yeah right yeah
Zach says I always love when a woman can
pull off really short hair for some
reason yeah it looks good on some people
not on me so much though I feel like I
don't look good with short hair you know
well uh when you had part of your head
shaved it was cool yeah but that's like
the rest of it was long yeah the rest of
it was long yeah because it's every now
and then because my hair is just such
it's funny but like before even before
we started live streaming um I was
telling pookie I was like Mommy sheds
more than you do like I shed hair just
like all over the place seriously I can
every day and it doesn't matter like how
many times you vacuum or whatever I can
run my toes over the carpet in this
office and like pull up like a whole
bunch of hair because like I just shed
hair all the time but my hair never gets
any thinner like it's still like really
voluminous it makes a lot of a lot of
hair I just have I have a lot of hair
it's just kind of like and so every time
you wash it every time you come it's
just like this big [ __ ] ordeal and so
every now and then I'm always kind of
like man I should like just cut it
shorter like I said it doesn't look good
bald so a few times I've cut it like
right here like to my chin
and then it's like for a second I like
it and then the next day I'm like why
the [ __ ] did I do that now my head looks
like a [ __ ] bowling ball you know
what I mean like it looks like a big
round you look good with long hair the
part in the middle like that or bangs
and you look good with uh with your hand
with the sides shaved yeah like an
undercut yeah it looks good if you want
me to do it I mean I'll I'll shave it
back I've yeah I mean I just threw it
back but I don't know it looks good
though now I'm just kind of like maybe I
should shave it back off again yeah it
is a lot easier to deal with it looks
good I'll show you guys
you know I got pictures just in the
sense that it's not you know as hot it's
like it dries quicker
um you know I don't have to use as much
product I don't have to use much shampoo
or hair dye or anything like that I
actually did I actually did my uh roots
today but then I slapped a [ __ ] wig
over it anyways
because it hadn't really I watched it
this morning but like I watched all the
dye out and then it hadn't um
it dried but it didn't really dry dry
you know what I mean it's always kind of
like
I don't know it's hard to explain my
hair is like a really really strange
texture
John Smith said I've mentioned this
before I have long flowing locks grown
specifically to upset my prematurely
balding brother
look how cute so funny look how cute
Jenny's head was when it was shaved yeah
and that's it like put up in a bun on
the side but she's yeah I just pulled it
off it was shaved all around the uh the
sides and the back yeah I only had hair
on the top yeah yeah and I I cut that
hair for yeah I can cut hair
see
um
there's another one with her with her
head shaft
it's only a few years ago yeah that's
not that old enough yeah
and then she did that and that's it with
that's shaved with red
yeah that's actually not I mean the
ponytail is like the red that's not real
hair though it won't focus that's clip
on yeah part of it is the front is my
hair but the back is for some reason a
clip-on ponytails for some reason it
won't focus on it I don't know if you
keep moving it
there you go there it goes there you go
I think that's cute
super cute
yeah our friend Brian took that picture
yeah
if you want that back I'll cut it back
into you I don't know I'll think about
it
I think it's awesome
and then
um she had a lot of little
different haircuts
that was it when it was yeah that was
when it was short
oh yeah that's right I forgot about that
because that was really short yeah
that's probably the shortest it's ever
been yeah for a while and it's funny too
I'm reminded because every time I look
at my um driver's license because when
my driver's license picture was taken it
was my hair was just like to here and it
was bright red so I still have yeah so
now I'm like paranoid that I'm gonna get
pulled over because it still has the
same picture my driver's license so like
paranoid they're gonna get pulled over
they're like this is uh not you that was
back when Jen had her long hair and when
she used to show her boobs she's High
she hides her boobs now I don't hide
them yeah she doesn't wear this [ __ ]
low catch it that [ __ ] well I don't have
I don't have that shirt you don't have
that shirt anymore that [ __ ] was so hot
I don't have that shirt anymore yeah
I got pictures of Jen's [ __ ] boobs
they're so great
yeah she's at the club
with the [ __ ] low-cut dress
yeah look cute it was cute
we mean a huh
I got pictures of it yeah I know you do
yeah
I'm just you know we don't go out as
often as we used to and like I said a
lot of the shirts I don't have them
anymore yeah because they're old well
we'll get you some more
you know yeah we'll get you some more
it's not like you can't wear that
anymore you're you're uh I think you
actually look better than you used to
um because you've been run the bike
riding the bicycle uh HRT has helped you
some [ __ ] it's just you know I think
you look great
Zach says my mom has fibromyalgia and
hates the cold but she also has real
long hair that takes forever to dry yet
refuses to get short hair and it always
bugs me that she won't do it I mean I
understand
because I feel like that's something
that older ladies do they always kind of
like cut their hair short
I get it I do because like I said you
know my hair my real hair is not quite
this long well no it's actually probably
about this long
but um it's a pain in the ass though
you're not you're messing up the um I'm
gonna mess it up yeah you're messing up
that was right and you're messing up the
feed nobody can see it anyway yeah [ __ ]
doesn't [ __ ] it doesn't and you
messed up the um the light I'm pretty
sure you've already shown that already
yeah not on it but okay fine
see I'm gonna stop bragging on you then
well no I'm just saying that it's like
you keep
doing that everybody's seen those
pictures before
you had some a couple days ago where are
they
oh well that's good at least it's just
kind of like look how look how pretty
you were like a long time ago you're not
taking anymore what are you talking
about you're not taking well like I said
we never go anyplace so it's like I'm
not really again you know because I'm
broke and I'm always working so it's
like I don't really have the time or the
money or anything like that I can't
[ __ ] log into uh Facebook I don't
have my my password and all that [ __ ]
from this one
Tom Sykes says night of the comet is
free on YouTube to watch I just saw that
like right before I know like I didn't
watch the movie I'm just saying I just
saw that it was free and I know like
everybody was like telling us to do and
we still haven't done it maybe we should
do that for Sunday
I know I keep saying that we still
haven't done the review for um what do
you call it Jason and the Argonauts we
were supposed to do that today but
you left
so we'll do it again I guess we can do
it tomorrow yeah
[Laughter]
but you know everything's late like I
said but because
um this weekend I'm gonna try and
because remember how we were talking
about how I kind of wanted to like
revamp not you know I'm not going to do
like anything drastic or nothing but do
you like kind of revamp the logo and
um you know the social media sites and
uh uh you know do like new intros like
for the movie reviews and the episodes
and stuff like that so hopefully this
weekend I'll have time to like
work on that a little bit and then and
like I said probably going forward I
might have to do like slightly fewer
videos every week because I feel like
I'm getting to a point where I'm just
doing too many and I just don't have
time to make them as good as I want to
make them
because I kind of feel like oh my God I
didn't do one I didn't put one up today
or anything like that so and I might
stop doing it too because if any of you
guys are on our um patreon a lot of
times I would say like on Sunday I would
post oh these are all the videos that
are going up this week but the last few
weeks I've been getting like behind and
I haven't been able to post like you
know there'll be like one or two of them
that I don't get to and so I don't know
if I'm gonna stop doing that or if I'm
just gonna say
you know oh these are the ones that
might be up this week or or might not
like depending on if I have time to do
them or not I just put up one today
about um more of the uh spooky Looney
Tunes cartoons because I did it it's
over on scare Salon if you haven't seen
it which is my other channel
because remember a while back I did one
that was like the 10 best like horror
adjacent Looney Tunes cartoons like from
back in the day and then there were some
that I forgot so I did another one today
that was uh that was five
five of them Zach says what are you
thinking of doing for the show's new
look it'll be similar but
um like similar theme but I just kind of
I don't know I just I'm
I'm kind of like throwing different
ideas around I found some like kind of
cool
like inspiration
uh that I kind of was maybe I don't know
I'll show it to you and later maybe
and see what direction you want to go
because I can't really decide
but I don't know
it's always like it's really really hard
for me to
like I don't have that much trouble when
I'm doing graphic design for other
people like I still do like it's still
hard to think of something but
especially if they don't have any idea
of what they want that's the worst but
when I'm doing stuff for
for our show or for my own thing it
takes me forever
and I don't know why I think it's just
because
I get overwhelmed by like all the
possibilities I think is what it is
because I'm sitting there going well
this is for me so I can do like
absolutely anything I want I don't have
to worry about
oh it has to look like corporate for
this kind of thing or they have to use
this color you know what I mean because
when I work for other clients you have
like about a lot of limitations
but when you're doing stuff for your own
self you can make it look however you
want and I think that like
like I said I think that overwhelms me
because I'm just like oh I could do this
or oh I could do that or I could do and
then like I just and I'm just sitting
there going oh my God I'm just now I'm
like I can't now I can't do anything
because I'm like I'm just like all the
choices are piling on me and I can't
decide you know Tom Sykes said he he
would be fine with Side Tracks going
away because most shows are sidetracks
anyway that's true the thing is though
is that this is just a hangout show
yeah I mean to be honest it's like
this one is like um
the the most fun for me to do because
um what oh
she went in the cabinet come on out of
there come on get out of cabinet Pokey
don't go in there opening up the
cabinets and going in I don't know why
she wants to go in there there's nothing
in there there's nothing in there she
went in
that's like where that went in that's
where I keep my you know my coffee and
stuff like that okay have fun in there I
don't know what she's doing it goes into
the cabinet underneath the sink yeah
like it's a big deal and she's like oh
look she's like she's going to Narnia
yeah yeah there's like cans of coffee
inside of there uh about sidetracks is
that uh we're just hanging out tonight
yeah
anyway we would just call it something
else so get rid of it that's what I mean
it's like we would probably still be
live streaming on Friday anyway it's
just that it's like oh maybe we do like
a movie review or maybe or something
like that so it's just kind of like
this I like doing this show probably
more than any of the other ones well I
don't know about that but I mean just
because it's so it's easy chill it's
easy I don't have to do any um you know
I don't have to make any thumbnails for
it I don't have to do any research I
don't have to do anything like that
because that's like you know takes a bit
of time and I like doing that but I'm
just saying this one's easy because I
can just like come on and we can just
talk about whatever you know
David Parker said that uh yeah Jenny's
been a hottie since I've known her so I
can see Tom being one proud dude thank
you very much it's true
it's true
it's
true
Jenny's been a little bit down in the
dumps because she's been working so much
we've both been [ __ ] working a lot
we've been stuck in the house a lot
since the past two years yeah well yeah
it's not just us it's everybody it's not
just so much that too but it's just kind
of like because over the holidays like
like I was saying like I didn't yeah
like I've had a really
um you know uh I I really didn't have
like a lot of graphic design work this
year and [ __ ] like that money and
because what because when I'm my major
clients they still give me work but see
they had two businesses yeah they have a
um like a commercial property business
and they had they were starting like a
um like a tea business right and so I
was doing a lot of work for their tea
business but they decided they didn't
want to do that anymore because it
wasn't making any money so now I'm just
doing the stuff for their commercial
real estate and that's not nearly as
much right you know what I mean so
it's just kind of like that I still have
the same clients but they don't have as
much work and it might like pick back up
I'm trying to like look for some other
stuff like so if anybody because I've
been like applying for
you know kind of freelance or remote
work and [ __ ] like that because I'm
looking for yeah more stuff because man
the last couple months I've been like
really really yeah struggling yeah you
know
so I have it so I haven't really been
like in the best
frame of mind you know that family has
been really good at Jenny the past
couple years all the [ __ ] business
they've thrown it with
they're a successful real estate family
it's a whole bunch of them they're uh
they're Jewish American uh [ __ ] nice
people when we went down there to go see
him they [ __ ] hit us with whether or
not we were with the tribe type thing
we're like no we're not with the tribe
it didn't matter though [ __ ] they
they uh they were like okay you're still
on the team uh good good good people
yeah they're really nice because they've
been working for them for a long time
right yeah
right
um that's been [ __ ] what six seven
eight years now
well and you know what's interesting
they're not Floridians I think they're
from up North by uh by by their accents
I don't think yeah I think originally
from but yeah they it's a um it's a
commercial property they they basically
like sell commercial properties that's
all they like uh you know or manage
commercial properties or whatever and
it's
a married couple the woman's brother and
their dad yeah
um they run it yeah so and like I said
on the side
um you know she wanted to do this kind
of like
um kind of like high-end tees kind of
things so we were doing that for like
years and years like she went all in
like we did like a whole package thing
she went to trade shows I designed like
all the trade show [ __ ] and all like all
the booth and everything
but they just decided it wasn't worth it
anymore like they were spending too much
effort and too much money on it and it
wasn't they weren't really seeing much
return so you know so they were like
yeah we're just gonna like wrap that up
because like I said they had the other
business and not to make that makes a
lot of money so I guess they figured it
was just not worth it anymore so that
kind of sucked because I was getting a
lot of work from that but you know how I
got um you know how I got in touch with
them was that a guy remember the print
shop where I used to work back in 2013
where I got laid off in 2016. yeah that
guy
um there was a guy that used to come in
there all the time
uh and I still get work from him
occasionally but he uh he owns a store
where he sells like as seen on TV kind
of products and what you do like um he's
a wholesaler so it's like they have uh
they get products and then he's like
okay well this company has this product
that you know microwaves eggs or
whatever
um but you can package it any way you
want like it's the same product
essentially but you can call it what you
want and like make your own box and all
that other kind of stuff so I did like a
lot of packaging design for him and he
used to come in the store where I worked
and I used to do [ __ ] for him all the
time and when I got laid off from that
store which is closed now actually
um he recommended me to those people
yeah so it was like a referral you're
right and then I ended up getting more
work from them you know what we've been
you've been we've been with them so long
we need to send them some
of these days yeah send them some
[ __ ] wine or a [ __ ]
some kind of [ __ ]
treat basket one of these days
just because yeah [ __ ] how much
business we've done with them over the
years
it could be a good business partner
uh Tom Sykes says we should talk about
the Idaho student murders the Moscow
Slayer uh because he was just
apprehended so I'm writing that down
okay write that [ __ ] down I think I
should write that [ __ ] down write that
[ __ ] down thank you I am
um somebody asked if I was on upwork I
used to be
um I think that my uh what you call it
my account
um
didn't uh it went away I have to
probably go in there again but I was on
there for a while but I wasn't really
getting much from that
so I don't know I got to do a thing
tomorrow where I gotta do like a
you know on LinkedIn like some jobs that
you apply for they want you to do that
uh phone interview where like they ask
you questions you have to like record
your answers like they're talking to you
on the phone yeah so I have to do that
tomorrow but I'm not really sure like
what they're at what they're gonna ask
me so it's like
I hate God I hate doing job interviews I
really hate them what is the interview
for exactly I never knew well it's um
it's at a it's at a graphic design firm
okay you're gonna do one yeah okay yeah
we're just work from home huh
um this one I'm not sure it might be
this one might be in Orlando so I might
have to I might have to commute to it
but okay so you're through but I well I
don't know I don't know how it's gonna
go okay I've been looking for something
remote but if something comes up like
kind of locally then I'll go for that
too because like I said I'm just sick of
being broke you know yeah I didn't know
about this is the first I've heard of
this but no I totally I totally agree if
you [ __ ] want to go back out
and [ __ ] do the thing then do the
thing well I mean I don't necessarily
want to it's just that right to make the
bills right yeah I mean I would rather
still work remotely right and like 99 of
the stuff that I applied for was remote
we'll still be able to do the show I
guess huh yeah yeah we might I mean we
might have to shuffle times around and
things like that you know depending on
like what the hours are I mean ideally
it would be good if I could get
something remote and part-time I did
like refer I did um
I did uh apply for a bunch of that kind
of stuff too
because then that way
it wouldn't be like taking up too much
time but I don't know we'll see how it
goes we'll see how it goes okay
trying to get back into the [ __ ]
there it is
what'd you get kicked out the show yeah
I got kicked out yeah
got kicked out okay I'm back
if you guys could like share and
subscribe that'd be awesome
okay Richard Brown said after seeing the
advert yesterday I looked up your books
on Amazon got your two books of stories
in my basket We'll order them tomorrow
well thank you thank you very appreciate
that which books did you did you already
said the books of the of stories like my
short story okay yeah yeah like my
horror stories right yeah those are good
well I hope you like them check out look
man check out unseen hand too that one
will [ __ ] trip yeah and then the uh
uh the the unsolved [ __ ] murderers
[ __ ] uh unseen hand
no not uh what was it called
um Facebook well that's a Trilogy yeah
there's three of those those are good
yeah
yeah murder Hornet said you never
answered his question but he never asked
I don't know what the question was
I didn't see it right
I ain't worried about it I mean you can
ask it again because like I keep
scrolling and I try to keep up but it's
like it's really really hard
and you're talking about Jason and the
Argonauts saw that last night we're
gonna talk about it yeah well we watched
most of it and then like I fell asleep
because we had to watch the rest of it
right yeah my sleep is [ __ ] up do you
know what time I I got up this morning
or woke up what 4 a.m really I woke up
at 4am damn
and I was gonna go back to sleep and
then so I got back I I went to the
bathroom and then I got back in bed and
then I just laid there and I was wide
[ __ ] awake see this is what I did so
about five I just got up this is what I
like and made coffee this is what I do
people
we kind of go to bed early but I like to
listen to [ __ ] podcasts when I go to
sleep
and I won't quite go to sleep as fast as
Jenny does so I'll go in the man cave I
got another room over there and I'll
[ __ ] sleep on a day bed listening to
the [ __ ] I know I'm gonna wake up to
take a leak several times during the
night
getting old it's so funny yeah he's just
gonna plus we're drinking part of the
times and then
some I'm drinking I drink a lot of iced
tea too I'm gonna iced tea makes me pee
more than yeah around
three or four which is usually like the
first time or second time they'll go to
sleep or I wake up after that I'll get
in bed with Jim yeah
and I do this [ __ ] because I'm I'm
thinking that well I might be able to
catch her waking up at around six
and I get some ass
it never works out though man [ __ ]
every now and then every now and then
I'm like I wake up at [ __ ] like eight
and I'm like where's that [ __ ]
where'd she [ __ ] go she sneaks up out
of the bed and starts working
without service in her man okay I'm
gonna have to put a sign up you know
you're not going anywhere without waking
me up
because I love some of that some of that
morning action
it's [ __ ] ridiculous man it's not
getting ridiculous well sometimes I'm
out of all these [ __ ] anabolics to
[ __ ] I take all kinds of [ __ ]
weird ass performance [ __ ] drugs and
[ __ ] I'm ready you know I mean I'm ready
I'm ready for four women and she's
running from me you know well sometimes
you're like you're kind of trying to Mac
I mean it's like four in the morning and
I was like and I'm like and I'm trying
to go back to sleep because I'm like God
damn it I have a titty in one hand
it's [ __ ] beautiful and then she's
like I'm gonna go to sleep you know what
she said to me a couple days ago I was
[ __ ] macking the [ __ ] out of this
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] homing in I'm [ __ ]
coming in for the kill she goes
go ahead and do what you got to do I'm
gonna go to sleep
what she's like yeah just just go ahead
it doesn't matter
I was really tired I'm gonna go to sleep
so you want me to wake you up when I'm
done what are you asking for
well I just like I said
I don't know just it pisses me off
because
I really kind of hate I don't hate
getting up early because I feel like I
hate sleeping late actually I don't
really like sleeping late because I feel
like a loser and I feel like I don't get
anything done so I actually really like
waking up early but on the other hand I
also feel like a loser falling asleep at
9 30 p.m that also makes me feel like a
loser so
and you know but like this morning I
don't know man like I woke up
and it was four in the morning and I was
like okay [ __ ] and I'm like wide awake
and I said well maybe like I went to the
bathroom and then I came back and I was
like maybe I can go back to sleep and I
couldn't so it's five o'clock I just got
up
and then just make like pookie was so
excited she was like oh my God Mommy
you're awake and I was like yeah Jesus
Jason is saying that he remembers
[ __ ] what is it chasing the Argonauts
to the skeletons yeah from Jason the
Argonauts uh that's actually one of the
best scenes [ __ ] um I can't imagine
like Ray harryhausen I mean don't like
we won't because like we gotta like do a
review of that right but that he always
thought that was like his best work in
Jason and the artists which yeah I mean
it looks I can't imagine and I think Ray
harryhausen I think like he um he
largely works by himself
so I can't imagine
man I don't have the patience for that
kind of stuff so I just like really
admire people that
can like sit there and do that
meticulous little because that would
drive me [ __ ] crazy yeah I just
there's no way I could do that no way I
like I like [ __ ] that that I can do that
I see results like I mean right away
yeah I don't really want this like oh
we're gonna we're gonna shoot like shirt
30 frames today and then like five
months from now we'll see what it looks
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I decided I did not
have patience for that kind of stuff at
all so but so I really like admire
people that do
you know what I mean and anybody that
can do anything that's like really
really small and fiddly you know what I
mean I've always been like really in awe
of those people you know like the people
that um can make like little bitty tiny
I don't know like they make like little
Miniatures or you know it's like I'm
gonna write the entire Lord's Prayer
like on the head of a pin or some [ __ ]
like that like
I don't know like I I'm really like I
admire those people because there's just
no way I would I would go [ __ ] insane
doing that [ __ ]
I don't have the patience and I don't
have the manual dexterity for any of
that little fiddly kind of [ __ ]
I'm just like super clumsy I'm like all
thumbs
Zach says since I moved back in with my
parents I haven't been falling asleep
till 3am and waking up around 9 or 10.
I've never done that before in my life
um I lived like that for a long time
because I had a job at a newspaper
back in the 2000s
and I worked uh was it it was the night
shift I don't know if they call it third
shift it was from 5 30 p.m until 2
a.m yeah 5 30 p.m till 2 A.M yeah so um
so yeah that was the shift I worked so I
actually didn't usually get home until 2
30 and so I didn't go to work or go to
sleep until three and then yeah I would
wake up about nine or ten
so that's about well sometimes it was
earlier but
but I did that for [ __ ] I don't even
remember how many years is murder eight
years nine years his murder Hornets in
the [ __ ] he was earlier I don't know
where he went though I want to show
y'all
murder Hornet That's My Boy Over in
Mexico he lives around that Mexican boy
did he say you're allowed he's an army
yeah yeah I want to I want to show you
finally show you all a picture of murder
on it
there's [ __ ] murder Hornet right
there in the middle
of that [ __ ]
of that action right there
hold on I can't get that [ __ ] to [ __ ]
yeah that's him in the middle
I can't get that [ __ ] to [ __ ]
there you go there he is some of that
[ __ ] Narco [ __ ] cartel action
that's that's murder horse Christ yeah
that's murder on it
you need to calm down I'm just throwing
[ __ ] everywhere it fell
yeah Zach says I've always gone to sleep
between 10 and midnight I'm up by six or
seven yeah I usually fall asleep but
like nowadays
um I usually fall asleep about 10
although I think I stayed up last night
because we discovered on Hulu that they
had put up season 13 of Hoarders and we
were like
you're watching that I love Horrors and
I was like wait I don't think we've seen
this season I don't think I think it was
from last year but I don't think we saw
it so I was like very excited I like
that they um that they now use the whole
hour because it's a long show
and that they now use the whole hour to
focus on one person because I feel like
the older Seasons they used to switch
back and forth between two and I don't
like that as much I kind of like the
like the deep focus on the one person
man that first woman they had well this
is kind of true of most of the people
that are on here sadly but um man that
first woman they had on there was uh
she didn't seem crazy at first like she
seems like started taking her she seemed
pretty well a lot of them are like yeah
like a lot of them are like pretty chill
it's like yeah I'm like so excited about
doing this and they seem to know that
it's bad and everything but then the
second you start taking I was like hey
can we throw away this old egg carton
with mold on it no you know what I mean
then they flip out like I know that it's
like not rational but honestly
um and I said this to him last night we
were watching it
I said I that's another kind of person
that I admire is I admire any
psychologist who would willingly
um specialize in dealing with hoarding
disorder no man because you must God you
must be like have the patience of a
saint because honestly I'm just watching
the [ __ ] on TV and I want to strangle
these people yeah and I know that that's
bad I know that they can't help it I
know but it's like it doesn't make it
any less I'm like God I just want to
punch this person there's no normal
thinking there that's what I mean and
it's like that's really really it's hard
for me to deal with and I said and I'm
not even there with them I'm just
watching their ass on TV it's like and
it's frustrating me so goes I'm here I'm
here yeah
murder Hornet was in the [ __ ] chat
earlier talking about New Year's evil
yeah didn't we do that movie though yeah
no we did Christmas evil yeah that's a
different movie okay we haven't done a
few years I don't think
I don't know man we've done so many
movies yeah
yeah murder horn it's my [ __ ] uh
Borderland he's my Borderlands [ __ ]
Mexican
[ __ ] uh
Mexican-American [ __ ] um dude who
he's my dispension
he's my dispatcher you look at him and
he's he's up there with his [ __ ] AK
and all these other guys he with all
these [ __ ] Narco agents and [ __ ] you
go what the [ __ ] is that
but then in the next shot you understand
that that's [ __ ] murder hornet in the
movie that he started
I got another photo photograph of murder
Hornets dead on the ground with blood
everywhere murder Hornet was in a movie
called
what's it called procedure di poderi the
price of power and it was a [ __ ]
movie about cartels
and in the movie he [ __ ] um gets shot
and gunned down and [ __ ] up but but
that that's what that photographs was
from that was from the movie that
[ __ ] murderhorn it was in
but he does live on the Mexican border
and they said they never paid his ass
for that movie
for being in that movie I mean that's
about par for the course I feel like
anytime I do kind of feel like I mean
anytime you're like any kind of creative
thing because I've had this happen to
you like as a graphic designer as an
artist yeah I mean most of most of my
clients pay me but a lot of times every
now and then yeah like people are just
kind of like oh they just conveniently
forget you know what I mean yeah and
then they disappeared you can't find
them right so you know there's that kind
of stuff happening all the time and I'm
just kind of feel like look it's like
nowadays we have canva we have all that
kind of stuff like if you don't want to
pay somebody do it just go on there and
do it your [ __ ] self then like Jenny
did some voice over and a song for a
[ __ ] movie that was [ __ ] evidently
voted one of the worst movies ever
remember that movie that we went to the
thing that evidently was [ __ ] that
kid that was also involved in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sent us the the links to the
ratings they said it was the worst worst
movie of all times that movie
we never saw it it was just some
it was a movie made by a pizza delivery
boy
which you know nothing against pizza
delivery yeah I'm sure some of them are
like really talented filmmakers I'm just
saying yeah this guy wasn't well yeah he
was he was an old guy from California
over here
delivering pizzas and trying to make a
money at the same time and it ended up
on Netflix
I don't even remember the name of them I
don't know if it wasn't on Netflix it
was on I thought it was on 2B 2b's out
it was either two beer Netflix and uh it
evidently was the worst movie of all
time
I mean it kind of seemed like it would
be just from the script
although you're singing and it was great
you think I thought it was cool I
listened to you I listened to you record
it I was like okay it's like a punk rock
song I don't know if they use me though
because I wasn't in the movie like at
the end in the end they put somebody
else in it I think everything was all
just kind of [ __ ] um cobbled together
in that movie so I don't know if they it
was probably he's my singing or not I
hope not
I don't think I don't think I sang that
good but
it sounded cool to me okay whatever it
just sounded like punk rock music
you know how I am about what's like yeah
yeah that's the thing it's like I I
think I can sing but it's like I'm not
singing in front anymore I thought it
was cool
that was one of the most stressful
things I ever did really yeah okay no I
thought it was cool
because and it's dumb because I I know
it's dumb like when I'm in the house by
myself like you know I sing and I'm like
wow I sing pretty good but it's just
kind of like I would never sing it for
you we talked about that movie early on
in the show we were doing the show when
that [ __ ] happened that's right I forgot
and then um [ __ ] that dude turned out
to be a douche [ __ ] uh
um early on and then he he ended up like
kind of getting kicked out of the club
and
he tried to recruit some of our friends
to be in his movies and it just wouldn't
work that didn't have any Talent he was
a hack he was a hack movie producer
slash director
from who had been banished from
California evidently
and he was over here working as a pizza
delivery man
and uh that was a trip
you just kind of watered into the club
he seemed cool at first but then the
more I started to [ __ ] pay attention
to him most people what's that isn't
that true of most people what's that
they seem cool they seem cool but then
and then you get to know them you're
like okay you kind of suck yeah
damn
oh well
very few people like that you meet are
like kind of cool just all the way
through they tried to make a goth
musical movie and he knew nothing about
the gothic subculture nothing well he
did but like from a long time ago like
he hadn't really late 70s early 80s
maybe which is fine if you wanted to do
something for back then but I think he
was trying to do stuff that was
contemporary but he didn't know that
like he didn't know what contemporary
was right like he didn't really know
like what was going on in the [ __ ] and
he was older than us yeah he was much
older yeah he was like in his late 50s
or something yeah late 50s early 60s
so he was like into the [ __ ] originally
but like I said he hadn't really
kept up with it or kept yeah
contemporary with it and like I said you
can still get away with doing like retro
[ __ ] there's nobody saying that but the
way he was going about it was not all
wrong was not gonna work out
um
what I was talking about uh people that
make Miniatures and Zach said so like
Annie from hereditary yeah that's kind
of what I was thinking and then John
Smith said there's that guy that carved
sculptures under the heads of matches
that's right I've seen that guy that's
[ __ ] amazing see like that kind of
[ __ ]
man more power to you I just wouldn't
have the [ __ ] patience or like I said
the coordination to do that Hugo said
Ray harryhausen is one of the reasons I
do stop motion I'm a puppet fabricator
so I don't have a say on the script and
most of the time scripts suck yeah I
kind of feel like Ray harryhausen he was
kind of one of the few people that a lot
of times and I think Jason and the
Argonauts was um an example of this was
that they would a lot of times kind of
tailor the movie to his specific
talents you know what I mean so they
would kind of change some [ __ ] around so
it's like hey we want him to make this
particular monster so let's write
something like that so he didn't get any
writing credit or nothing but they
always kind of like wrote stuff around
like what he would make because he was
so well known you know
Zach says goth musical I'd watch that
well so would I but that's not what he
made
see yes I mean it yeah I'm trying to
think of like I mean I yeah I would
watch that too if it was a good one yeah
I can't really think of any kind of like
other than other than repo the Genetic
Opera which isn't yeah it's technically
well goth industrial it's like a goth
industrial-ish yeah one that one's
pretty good but
[ __ ] uh Sweeney Todd was kind of a
Gothic musical yeah but I'm talking more
about like a musical like with
contemporary with contemporary gothic
music that's like set in the gothic
scene like Grace but goth Greece ooh
yeah yeah making me want to see grease
now
actually yeah maybe we should watch
Greece after this you can watch it after
that that sounds fun well because
because of your you guys are gonna laugh
because you know how um you know how
Pookie is real into getting her her
little hair brushed yeah and so she'll
jump up over there on the sink where the
brush is and be and yell until somebody
comes over there and brushes her so it's
funny because Tom was over here brushing
her before the show and he was doing the
Because you know how in Greece
um it's Jan right yeah
the so-called fat girl that's totally
not fat she's adorable I actually really
like her yeah make a good porn star well
I like her character like she's just
like real funny and Goofy and I think
yeah she was doing the it's um I painted
toothpaste if you didn't know which is
like a pretty popular toothpaste in the
50s and that was like the commercial
that she was singing and it's funny
because I heard Tom over there going
like Brushy Brushy bread I was like oh
my gosh
and it's like I do that too like without
that's why I laughed when you did it
because I was like holy [ __ ] I do the I
do the Ipana brush or brush the song too
yeah but except it's Brushy because
that's what we call it pookie loves a
[ __ ] you grab her right grab her head
and just brush one side in a single
Direction go Brushy Brushy Brush and
she's [ __ ] leaning in she's like yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and I have little if you know you
guys are gonna laugh too it's like I
have little wall mounted brushes that
are up there and they're mounted on the
on the corner of the wall so like when
she jumps up on the sink I can brush her
on this side and then she can brush
herself on the other side of the wall
like she on the other side of the of her
face
because she's got her own little
self-service brush on the side she just
loves getting brushed not even so much
she doesn't really care about her back
or anything like that she wants you to
brush her face like the sides of her
face she's real into having like her
little cheeks brushed yeah and she will
just sit there all day and like like
thank you very much lion Warrior thank
you very much bro
oh you must be like a couple like things
ahead no he's saying telling everybody
to [ __ ] hit the thumbs up yeah thank
you very much
uh Jeffy art could never get into Greece
every time I tell my friends they call
me a bad gay and then I need to tune in
my turn in my gay card yeah who said
that [ __ ]
Jeffy heart Jeffy go ahead throw in a
gay card I don't know why I love Greece
actually I love Greece too also which
maybe that's a controversial opinion but
I actually I'll go to bat for Greece too
yeah live television version of Greece
is I have that on [ __ ] Blu-ray also
that shit's good also I think that was
what 2015 2016 I think something around
that time they had a live television
show of Greece it was good
Tom Sykes says Earth Girls Are Easy is a
decent musical oh that's right I forgot
that was a musical
I kind of should watch that again
every now and then because remember when
Julie Brown was a thing not Downtown
Julie Brown the other Julie Brown the
white one with the red hair she had red
hair right if you don't like Sergeant
Pepper's [ __ ] [ __ ] throwing your
gay card also
well I'm I'm willing to give people a
pass on that because I understand that
like a lot of people we're not talking
about the album Sergeant Pepper
obviously everybody in the world likes
that album because it's amazing we're
talking about the movie that had the Bee
Gees in it yeah so it's like I
understand Aerosmith
well I don't know
was it oh yeah it was disco it was a
disco album I kind of have a soft spot
for I have a soft spot for that it was
great thank you very much thank you
grandthers just priming the Super Chat
pump for the night
pup let a [ __ ] make some movie
that that [ __ ] make some money
out of this [ __ ] Jeffy art says uh
about Greece however I do like the
theory that the story is actually Sandy
having a stroke and going to heaven oh
is actually about John Travolta [ __ ]
imagining that he was straight that's
what that's yeah maybe John Travolta is
having a stroke and imagining what it
would be like yeah what it would be like
if you [ __ ] it was straight Zach says
Jenny would you watch this a psychedelic
Thriller about people running from their
past set in Jamaica that's the next
script I might want to write I mean yeah
I would probably watch that to be honest
if it's good I'll watch pretty much
anything
uh Richard Brown says Phantom of The
Paradise yeah that's a good one love
it's good but I'm just saying that it's
like now that you mention it I don't
think that there's ever been
like a Gothic like with Gothic Rock like
but a musical no like in that same
framework I mean there I'm sure there
has been but it's like I don't I can't
think of one that was made into a movie
though I'm a phantom of the paradise
means he wants to see that again well
tonight we're just gonna have to do a
musical we're gonna watch Greece and fan
by the paradise yeah
people pretending that they were gay
watching the [ __ ] fan of his paradise
uh Victor says never heard of it I'm not
really sure like what one you're talking
about but let's talk about Victor it
might be the sergeant it might be the
Sergeant Pepper's musical yeah there was
a movie called
1978. I want to say all right Sergeant
Peppers the movie no 80 81 right later
I'm pretty sure it was nice it was nice
late 70s okay and um it was directly I
think it was Robert stigwood he like
directed at her producer it's a low
budget movie that's like one big long
music video that is a TR that is a
[ __ ] um
it is basically a
BG's tribute album
and excuse me a Beatles a Beatles
tribute album yeah performed by the Bee
Gees and Aerosmith and a couple of other
artists go come in there and they George
Burns is there yeah and they're Alice
Cooper is in it yeah Alice Cooper and
they're doing Beatles songs yeah and
Peter Frampton was in it yeah that's
right and they're trying to make like a
concept album out of of about [ __ ]
Sergeant Pepper and Mr Mustard
you just gotta see it to understand it
oh and Steve Martin was in it yeah he
was Maxwell Maxwell of Maxwell silver
hammer right all right real good
I saw that I feel like that was on
Cinemax like all the time like every day
I must have seen it 40 bajillion times
that was my introduction to [ __ ] uh
bondage [ __ ] robots
[ __ ] they had the dim black
shiny metabol shiny plastic robot girls
with all the [ __ ] lights they were
kind of like cylons remember that and
then Mr Mustard [ __ ] Out Mr Mustard
video they're kind of like they're kind
of like
kind of like bondage
BDSM kind of a [ __ ] fetish Motif too
it's a weird movie yeah it's a weird
movie yeah I mean the Bee Gees and Peter
Frampton are Star as Sergeant Pepper's
Lonely Hearts Club Band and they're from
a small town in like MidWest American
Americana um
we called Heartland
and there are all these musical
instruments right are they Matt they're
magical right magical yeah and
Mr Mustard steals them yeah yeah
something like that in his RV it's D
it's a disco movie
and the Beatles and metal early metal
and it's all just kind of
a musical you know
harder than Xanadu which is another good
movie I like that yeah Trey says my
personal favorite is xanadas yes
Xander dude was good I like Santa do as
well yeah is that sanity was Xanadu was
a pretty movie and it had a
I like musicals yeah I know it's a
musical is it dorky do you like musicals
yeah that's okay it's dorky and it's
it's gay
it's gay man it makes you a gay man all
right I'm you're a gay man I'm fine with
that yeah it's like it's like I
appreciate the show tunes
I don't like some music like some
musicals can die in a fire but it's like
a lot of them I just you know I don't
mind them actually no they're good yeah
I don't mind them and a lot of them I
actually really like I really I I really
like Greece yeah Greece was great Xanadu
[ __ ] repo the Genetic Opera
Sergeant Pepper's
Phantom of The Paradise Rocky Horror
yeah Rocky Horror
what else Hedwig in the Angry Inch did
you see that uh also you have you would
probably like that Hedberg and the Angry
Inch that's a newer one but that one's
amazing I love all the [ __ ] music in
that too also um Sweeney Todd The Demon
Barber of [ __ ] Fleet Street yeah I
tend to like ones that are horrory
obviously
Greece isn't horrory but I still like it
no Greece is all positive
yeah well well and I like the Retro
because I like that kind of like
rockabilly sensibility to it like you
know what I mean so I like that kind of
stuff about it
the picture says I hate Musicals A lot
of people do it's like you know it's
fine it's fine
better when you're drunk
they're yeah they're more fun they're
more fun well you used to you used to be
in them oh yeah you were you know Grand
thefters will send one too you were in
you were in the same ones we were in the
same drama program yeah we were in music
musicals were harder to do but they were
they were more fun
we did Pippin uh and we did [ __ ]
Joseph and the Amazing Technicolor
Dreamcoat and then later on I [ __ ]
starred in [ __ ] the Fantastics later
on as El Gallo just [ __ ] singing the
she was kind of like the main bad guy
but yeah so I was in that [ __ ]
in in
um Joseph I did the pharaoh
which did an Elvis number
yeah that's right it was the Elvis
rip-off number yeah
that's awesome yeah in Pippin I wasn't
[ __ ] it wasn't [ __ ] uh good enough
then at that time [ __ ] our friend
Steve had the had the leading role in
Pippin he played Pippin
and that I don't remember the songs
grandpas might remember them but uh we
did a bunch of [ __ ] and then we did
other just rather black box theater and
[ __ ] did private Wars
um did a bunch of other little ones
um no I loved acting it was good
but you don't want to do that for a
living you know yeah we've talked about
that before no
no you don't want to do that for a
living if you're dependent on [ __ ]
Hollywood [ __ ] Deb
you have a lot of Hollywood actors that
just say [ __ ] Hollywood and they want to
go back to these little theaters yeah
because it's instant gratification you
can do a live performance in front of an
audience and you well yeah I kind of
feel like a lot of actors who are into
acting like for the craft a lot of them
prefer stage acting because like you
said it's well it's kind of like doing a
live stream it's like doing a live
stream because you're kind of like
getting instant feedback yeah instant
feedback and it's a smaller audience and
you can interact and it's it's more
personal thing and
you're trying to put on a show for them
and deliver I mean to be honest like if
I was an actor which I'm not because I'm
too self-conscious but if I was like I
can't imagine it sounds like a nightmare
like shooting a movie because everything
is they shoot everything out of order
yeah you have to like do these brief
little scenes
um you know over and over and over again
until you get it right and it's like
from different angles and all this other
kind of stuff I don't understand and so
in a way like when you see a performance
in a movie that's really really good I'm
always kind of like man I'm gonna that's
amazing because it's like it's just so
piecemeal and like cobbled together the
fact that there's any like continuity at
all of that character is like amazing to
me yeah it is because it's like I could
never [ __ ] do that I'd be like who
the [ __ ] am I now right what's going on
right you know I'd be like that like
every single scene a live performance
there's a middle a beginning there's a
beginning a middle and an end right it's
a Story in real time right and and you
know who the audience is you've been
[ __ ] looking at them and you've been
delivering the you've been delivering
the goods to them and you can tell if
they're if they're into it or not which
if he didn't if you know what I mean
you're feeding off of that that can only
happen in a very small theater and I see
a small theater like people under a
theater under 2000 you know that's full
um oh somebody's thank you Victor yeah
what are y'all's New Year's resolutions
uh I don't really have one I never make
New Year's resolutions because then I'll
just beat myself up if I don't do them
right right but well I mean I do have
things that I I want to do like over the
year like I want to finish the novel I
was working on I have another game that
I want to make which I kind of started
but I've you know I haven't got that far
on it because I haven't had time
um you know [ __ ] like that make more
money that would be nice yeah that's the
main thing win the lottery that's that's
my New Year's resolution like so I don't
have to [ __ ] worry about [ __ ] anymore
that'd be nice yeah
yeah but I mean I definitely want to
finish that novel though in that game
that I wanted but that's kind of like
um
yeah granther said Graham was one of the
brothers in Joseph Tom was Elvis her
friend was Joseph also Marilyn ricegum
was one of the sisters yeah if you guys
know Marilyn ricegum is she was she
starred in [ __ ] a TV series called 24
yeah she was on 24 yeah she was actually
she's my ex-girlfriend we're still
friends
we [ __ ] she's seen the show she's
also liked a lot of [ __ ] that we've
[ __ ] done she loves Jenny she says
she's [ __ ] really cute that's what
she said about you really yeah she's
like she's really oh a famous person
yeah she says I'm cute yeah it's like I
just watched that uh real stop-motion
thing the other day she thinks I'm cute
Maryland was [ __ ] cool and Mary Lynn
was she's a comedienne really uh you
know she's done a lot of acting she it
actually really is funny grandsters will
tell you
that chick was [ __ ] goofy man she was
funny as [ __ ] as a kid did it really
funny
she her her sense of humor is a lot more
adult than it was you know because we're
we're grown up you know we're older now
when she was a kid she was just [ __ ]
hilarious super Goofy
everybody loved her she's funny
cute too I like funny people yeah funny
people yeah
uh thank you very much we got two super
chats one from Jeffy art it's
interesting to compare the acting
culture of LA versus New York City yeah
there's a big difference in London well
that too yeah he said La seems very
commercial or superficial whereas
Broadway still has Bohemian Roots yeah
cause like I said I kind of feel like
New York City that's where you want to
go if you want to like be an actor
because that's where all the stage [ __ ]
is yeah you know what I mean whereas if
you want to be in the movies you know
you go to La so there is kind of like a
different kind of thing there yeah
although I'm gonna say this and [ __ ]
this is the truth okay the best
English-speaking actors are from England
yeah those dudes are [ __ ] great man
they're really good
they take the craft very seriously
um I mean I would take it seriously if
that was my job it's an art form just
like any other art form yeah you know
what I mean don't [ __ ] on it the British
have been the best for [ __ ] 100 years
easily you know more than that it goes
back to Shakespeare they're really they
take that [ __ ] super seriously look at
the movies that they've made
look at the the American movies that the
British made
a lot of things that you think are
America are American are actually
British like Star Wars that's a British
movie
you know even though you had an American
cast or the leads were American All The
Supporting Cast and everybody on the
crew and everything crew yeah
you go back to British movies and they
look at a lot of the best American [ __ ]
from [ __ ] off the damn [ __ ] Netflix
you know [ __ ] Walking Dead and [ __ ]
all the best actors off that were
British
and [ __ ] the dude that these these
dudes are good enough to wear you know
me being Southern
I'm thinking I'm looking at a southern
actor and it's the turn of the British
guy
but they can do I remember you being
shocked when you found out that Andrew
Lincoln was British yes absolutely
shocked I think a lot of people knew
because he'd been in love actually that
British like Christmas Romance movie or
whatever so he'd been in that so a lot
of people had heard him talk before but
yeah I had actually forgotten because I
don't like Love Actually he was like
something straight out of Georgia or
Alabama you know I was like I was like
that's that's a southerner
you know
no he's British yeah
no
well wait a minute we had another Super
Chat that I did I didn't get done all
right
um thank you very much Zach Betty Davis
said if you impressed a film crew with
acting you know you did a good job
because Crews have seen everything right
regular audiences are more easy to
impress okay that's like a good
yeah I guess that's like a good gauge
isn't it right
Victor says I heard all the zombies in
Walking Dead are Meryl Streep she's that
good
yeah yeah
Richard Brown said Idris Elba say Elba
too yeah because he's been in a lot of
yeah sometimes yeah sometimes I'll see a
movie and it's like I'm not even
thinking about it and I just think like
it's an American dude or something like
that and then you see him in an
interview later and I'm like oh that's a
Brit again yeah I think the only real
Southerners out of the [ __ ] The
Walking Dead was a dude that played
Merle Dixon tomorrow
what was his name um but he's uh he's
from Mississippi
and then the guy who played Daryl might
be
Norma renas I think he might be Southern
yeah I can't remember where he's from
he's from the south somewhere yeah
and uh you would never know you would
never know that that British dude that
was in there with them was
wasn't Southern interestingly
um Andrew Lincoln
Andrew Lincoln yeah he was he's the main
guy like Rick Rick
um he was in an episode of Cabinet of
Curiosities the gay armor Del Toro
Netflix series and he played An American
in that too although he played in New
Englander yeah so and he did like pretty
good I thought and also it was him and
um Essie Davis who is also playing an
American even though she is Australian
because she was in the babadook now who
was the guy that played [ __ ] um uh
Merle um he was also uh Michael Rooker
Rooker that's right my he was also in uh
yeah
he was in Slither Slither yes
that's the shitty worm he was in a bunch
of mood yeah
I'll watch I'll watch anything Michael
Rooker is one of those actors he's good
it's just kind of it's him like Jeffrey
Combs Bruce Campbell he's like one of
those kind of actors it's like I don't
even care if the movie's shitty I'm
gonna if you're in it I'm gonna watch it
yeah he's one of those guys Rooker was
also in that very last really good uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger movie it was
called fifth day or sixth day some [ __ ]
like that uh he played he played one of
the [ __ ] Hitmen in that that's right
Rooker was good because he was
he was he was authentic he was an
authentic Southern dude he had
um he had a hardness to him
and if you look at him what was funny is
that he was a very deceptive actor
when I first saw him in that Henry
portrait of a serial killer that
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me
he did he was so good and I thought I
was seeing a real serial killer with
that yeah I was and and to watch him
[ __ ] basically psychologically and
physically torture those [ __ ] women
and [ __ ] before I was I was kind of like
God damn I was [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
up movie it really freaked out by that
damn movie
but what was weird about it is that he
was horrific he was a horrific dude
but if you stood back and looked at him
he was very handsome that was a very
yeah handsome dude who could convince
you that he was a [ __ ] monster
um
yeah he's [ __ ] great yeah he was
[ __ ] really good he's one of those
actors see and we've talked about this
before like the distinction I guess this
is disappearing somewhat but it's still
kind of like a distinction that people
make between like your A-list like big
you know actors and stuff that can like
you know open a movie it's like your Tom
Cruise type characters like I said
that's he's like older now and then you
have character actors which means you
know you're never gonna be like a
romantic lead or you're never gonna like
Elite and that's like a shame because a
lot of the Time character actors are way
more interesting because the thing about
these kind of like A-list big actors
it's like a lot of them are like you
know maybe good looking or they're in
these big franchises and stuff but
there's not really much to them
otherwise they just have like some kind
of charismatic star quality but somebody
like Tom Cruise or Will Smith or
somebody like that it's like you know
depending on the role they're fine but
it's like they always kind of play the
same role they're always like themselves
because they're bigger than life whereas
I feel like character actors are
actually like actors yeah before they're
movie stars and so I to that to me
they're a lot more interesting I enjoy
watching those kind of people more than
big stars when Rucker was doing Merle
when he was doing Merle
and [ __ ] The Walking Dead I bought
that 100 percent
I believe that there was a moral like
that was a real person
yeah that and that's like
that you know that's a great sales job
you really have to be a good actor to
get you to get a person to buy
especially I was a trained actor I'm
buying it that there was a Merle Dixon
you know
that's where it was a Merle dick my yeah
brought it to me I'm like okay yeah yeah
my gauge is you know do I forget that
that's an actor right yeah I forgot who
that was
I was like okay yeah yeah yeah it didn't
occur to you that that was like like you
get totally immersed and and and and his
younger brother Daryl Dixon I bought
into that too
for for as long as I watched that series
that series started to go sideways
towards Norman Reedus is from Florida by
the way from Florida that's still
Southern yeah so he's got it that's it
right he's from Hollywood Florida
Hollywood Florida he uh he was down here
doing one of the horror conventions I
remember that's right yeah yeah it went
like three hours to see him yeah he had
one of the longest the lines was [ __ ]
giant to see him you know what everybody
that I know that has met him said he's
just he's great he's the nicest man it
would be great yeah said that he is just
like really really humble and he's just
like really you know he's super famous
but you could make whole movies with
Norman Reedus [ __ ] they need to get
him out of the [ __ ] Walking Dead put
him in the damn [ __ ] the story world I
mean he's yeah I mean he's been in
movies but he was actually blade he was
he was yeah but he was in um who's that
[ __ ] movie called the uh
what's the one with the about the Hitman
God damn it uh which hit man I'm getting
old I can't remember about the Hitman
all I can remember I don't think you saw
it okay but it's like it's a pretty
somebody will remind me I'm sure
because it's like it's a famous movie I
just can't I just blanked on the title
at the moment
um but Boondock Saints thank you that's
what it was Boondock Saints uh so yeah
that was probably his best known movie
role but I loved him in
if you guys saw Masters of Horror the
John Carpenter one like episode that was
called cigarette Burns he was in that
and Udo Kier was in that and that was
like that's probably my favorite episode
of that whole series
um Tammy says they're gonna do a Daryl
Dixon spin-off are they yeah I heard
that camp guys talking about it says uh
John Malkovich I actually love John
Malkovich he's one of my favorite actors
of all time John Malkovich Jeremy Irons
like I like anybody like that
um John Malkovich actually my favorite
role of his was probably
Dangerous Liaisons which is one of my
favorite that's one of my favorite
movies of all time I love that [ __ ]
movie I've seen it like a million times
ah
I've seen it a million times
um yeah they're talking about Gene
Hackman
um yeah see to me like I don't and this
is male actors female actors whoever
um I just think I I like character
actors who they call it they're just
more interesting I don't really like
these just kind of like stars you know
what I mean because they're just very
samey like a lot of times you see a
movie and it's fine they're fun and it's
you know
and it's like a good time and everything
but it's like I don't really I don't
really buy them as I kind of feel like
and I know you're gonna get on my case
about it but that's kind of why I'm not
like a huge fan of Tom Cruise because
it's like every single movie that he's
in and same with like Will Smith or
people like that it's like you know
they're fine as far as it goes but
whenever you see a movie you're like oh
it's Will Smith or oh it's Tom Cruise
it's like you he never like disappears
into a role where you forget that that's
an actor that's never gonna happen
they're just they're too big
to disappear into a role and I'm not
saying that that can't happen because I
mean Tom Cruise has been in stuff like
he was in Magnolia he was in like some
stuff that
um like I said when he plays a bad guy
or he plays an [ __ ] like then it's
easier for him to like get a murder and
I'm not saying that it's not because
look at [ __ ] um Tom Cruise is good
though man no I know I know I know he
yeah
but the thing about it is that you know
even people that are like super super
famous and this is one thing that I
always kind of think of look at like um
Charlize Theron right who is one of the
most beautiful women on the planet she's
a massive massive star and everything
like that when she was in that alien
warnose movie
I forgot you forgot who that was that
that was I forgot that alien Warnes was
dead I thought that I was watching alien
warnos yeah just she just oh vanished
into that role and that I watched I saw
in the theater and for a time I was
watching it going holy [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] right here and then I was like
holy [ __ ] I forgot I forgot the alien
the real alien where this was dead that
was like an actor playing her and that
very very rarely happens the only other
time that's happened was when Martin
Landau played Bella Lugosi yeah in
Edward you forget that I forgot that
that was Martin Landau the thing is with
Cruz thank you Senor sticks what would
he say must it be the last stream of the
Year well we're gonna do a stream on
Sunday we're gonna do a stream on Sunday
yeah I'm just saying it's the last one
of 2022. like you know what I mean to
make it sound more dramatic what we're
gonna do is if we're gonna do one on
Sunday like we usually so yeah
um
what were you talking about you're
talking about um Martin landauer land
down and okay Edward I was gonna go back
to I was going to go back to to Cruz
there's a certain Cruz does certain
roles based upon
he wants to be in certain kind of movies
yeah and
um there are certain things he can do
and there's certain things he can't do
so I understand why he ends up in the
movies that he does yeah but he does
have a bit of range
um the yeah I'm not saying that he
doesn't I thought he did a great let's
stop uh it is not like the book Lestat
but I thought he did a great little
start he did
um a good set he did a real good
assassin and collateral he can play a
bad guy
um I like him better when he plays a bat
yeah yeah he's a good bad guy
but he can't be a bad guy all the time
or they would or it would be like [ __ ]
it you know like what they said and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood where you got a
[ __ ] Bob Crane kick in tight pants
kicking your ass all the time and then
um but he uh
no he he he's been good
at least good in everything I thought he
was great as Ethan wasn't it was his
name Ethan Hunt from the [ __ ] him from
from um yeah I'm not saying he's not
good I'm just saying that he can't
vanish into a role in the same way that
a quote-unquote character actor can I
think he probably could that's what I'm
thinking I think he could
but I think his management and his
[ __ ] uh what do you call it his uh
his people won't let him take certain
roles because they don't want to hurt
his career that's what I think it is
um I think I think well here here okay
I'm gonna tell you okay when I was a kid
growing up
Dustin Hoffman was considered the
greatest [ __ ] American actor of all
times
okay because he could disappear into a
role but you go back and look into that
[ __ ] not really that's Dustin Hoffman I
mean he's still Dustin he still does the
top but he disappears into a role more
than Tom Cruise does I would argue I
think Tom Cruise could do better
I
mean the thing about it we've talked
about this before like uh most actors
have
um you know I think
well most actors have roles that they
get comfortable with whether that's what
they want to do or not but it's like
because sometimes they get Typecast you
know so that's always just kind of like
the roles that they play Charlize Theron
is [ __ ] a better actor than or
actress than either of those two she's
just yeah big time she just is Charlize
Theron is amazing yeah and the thing
about it is that
I mean she's like as glamorous as [ __ ]
but then like she's in something like
monster or she's in something like Fury
Road oh yeah she's fantastic Prometheus
yeah she's fantastic yeah she she's
better than Tom Cruise and and yeah and
[ __ ] and Dustin she's believable like
I said I don't think I've ever seen a
movie with Tom Cruise in it that I
forgot that that was Tom Cruise ever
she's just she just isn't a call and
much attention you know she doesn't she
just she
she's not real well known or you know
well she's very well known what am I
talking about yeah she's just not
attracting the attention because
Hollywood Theater is not what it once
was had she appeared 20 years ago or 30
years ago she would have been a [ __ ]
Classics she's a late Comer to this seed
and this is towards of the end of
Hollywood if you ask me
um
but she she's a she's great she's real
great she's very underappreciated
um I think some of it is partly because
she plays female roles
female roles tend not to be leads they
tend to be supporting roles although it
wasn't in [ __ ]
um monster
and monster is just great but not a lot
of people went to go see monster got it
Monster is so good most people go to
it's not a fun time no or anything but
it's a great [ __ ] movie most people
go to see these [ __ ] Temple movies
and they tend to have male leads and I'm
not super into that like I enjoy them
but they're not they're generic yeah I
don't really like I mean if I'm gonna
watch some Cinema that's not what I'm
gonna watch you know what I'm saying as
far as as far as actors go
female actress [ __ ]
well okay I'm gonna say [ __ ] Theron
is [ __ ] the best female actor if you
[ __ ] did she's the best actress I
mean she's one of the best ones I can
think of that's still and and up there
with the males I mean
right now oh yeah
easily
easily she might be the best actor
she might be
[ __ ] it's got to be in the running I
would think well the thing about her is
that she has a great I mean she just has
great range right she can play all kinds
of different roles and she never sticks
out as being like not believable you
know what I mean she's always believing
and as far as males actors go Julianne
Moore that's another good pick yeah I
like her too as far as male actors go
with contemporary what's going right now
I must say [ __ ] Tom Hardy I love Tom
Hardy Tom Hardy can do anything and and
if it requires physicality he's going to
do that
he'll get jacked if he has to he'll get
fat if he has to he'll get [ __ ]
skinny if he has to and that [ __ ] can
act okay every [ __ ] movie I've seen
he's hardcore Hardy brings it
big respect all right
and
Theron and Hardy are real [ __ ] close
yeah I'd probably say that that might be
it right there you know
they might be maybe that's why Fury Road
like made me squeeze so hard yeah that's
right yeah yeah damn it I loved that
movie we saw that movie we saw Mad Max
Fury Road we saw six times yeah in the
theater and we've seen it a bunch of
times since then yeah I own it and it's
like that's one I never get sick of that
one of the best movies God damn it it's
so good it's so good and I just love
that movie yeah
that whole series is one of the best the
weakest entry is the American entry from
the Thunderdome well the rest of them
yesterday and ones are [ __ ] great
[ __ ]
um hey the Australians can make a movie
man when they want to the kiwis candles
when they want to that that's a [ __ ]
great Direction Just most of the time
they're just kind of like yeah they
don't give a [ __ ]
but every time I've seen like an
Australian movie I'm just like God damn
that was that was a [ __ ] amazing
movie
when they make when they want to make a
movie they just kind of come in and be
like here's our movie and they're like
Ah that's like way better than our movie
what the [ __ ] like they made parasite
but I saw the devil really trained a bus
on holy [ __ ] Jesus Christ you guys
you're you're making us look bad I mean
when Fury Road came out they were like
get the [ __ ] away back the [ __ ] up
here's a movie
and people were like hell yeah hell yeah
that's the movie that's a [ __ ] movie
you're right that's a movie
and you know that doesn't happen very
often though what's his name George what
George Miller George Miller yeah George
I just imagine and George said another
movie was coming I mean George Miller is
like the oldest he's old as dirt he
better get out and the funny thing is
that he came out like I kind of feel
like oh action movie action movie and
then he's like pardon me gentlemen and
then like that movie comes out and he's
like thank you bye yeah and everyone was
like he said you know people were like
well when's the next one coming out he
says it's coming out soon we're going to
make it he may have been bullshitting
but then they said what happened if you
die and he said that mad the Mad Max
property was in good hands that he had
given it to guys who understand who knew
yeah yeah so we'll see
Zach had given us another Super Chat
okay he says I find the most talented
American actresses to me are
African-American I don't know why they
seem more genuine emotionally open I
guess yeah maybe maybe that's what you
got to name something maybe that's what
it is I mean I don't know [ __ ] for me
Eddie Murphy I grew up watching Eddie
Murphy movies and a lot of that didn't
have to do with his acting skills it was
a lot of that had just had to do with
his character and the scripts
but somehow like with him it works
though it worked just because he was
such he was so like Charming yeah I was
with [ __ ] Eddie through all the
[ __ ] Beverly Hills cops the [ __ ]
um uh what's the one where he was stuck
in 48 hours another 48 hours that looks
good it was before Beverly Hills Cop and
then uh man you know I like Vampire in
Brooklyn and I was goffed out at that
time as a goth kid I liked Vampire in
Brooklyn but I'd seen [ __ ] Blacula
all right and scream Blacula scream so I
don't think people understood the
context of a [ __ ] black a [ __ ] um
of Vampire in Brooklyn uh I got it you
know I mean that was a great movie
um
Eddie Eddie Eddie when and then his new
[ __ ]
Dolomite is my name [ __ ] fantastic
movie yeah I love that movie and uh
Coming to America one and two coming to
America too was good
um not as good as the first one but no
it was because it was PG is why if it
was already to be better yeah they
really needed enough but uh he he's
working on new [ __ ] you know
Eddie Murphy was is a throwback to
another era but it was a better era okay
he can deliver if he's got if he's got
support behind him
Murphy's going to be able to make a good
[ __ ]
now some people are saying well his [ __ ]
sucked all that Mr doolitor Doolittle
and this and that Haunted Mansion yeah
I guarantee if you go back and watch
those old movies you'll enjoy those more
than some of this new [ __ ] that's out
well I don't know about that no
something it was all pretty good the
standards were higher back then
I don't know about that either
some of the [ __ ] they make today [ __ ]
sucks you can go back and watch that
stuff it's just entertainment
maybe it's when you have a when you have
a bunch of hits
okay and then you come out with
something that's good or it's not good
enough is the way they feel about it
well the thing yeah if if you come out
the gate swinging and you make like all
this really awesome [ __ ] yeah like yeah
anything some good anything you make is
like not gonna like live up right I
think that was part so in a lot of ways
you should probably start out shitty
exactly so then that way
don't don't come right out the gate with
like oh my God it's the best movie ever
because then everything like that ever
after that's gonna be like a lit with
the Murphy products the the the the bar
was set high from the beginning so he
was already [ __ ] kind of shooting
himself in the foot
but I I yeah [ __ ] some of this [ __ ]
that's long forgotten I I have this [ __ ]
on Blu-ray or or DVD and I'll go in
there and I'll watch it and I [ __ ]
love it like I love Golden Child
I you know what I love that I think I
said this before but it's like I really
really loved that movie in the 80s but
then when I saw it again I was like I
don't like this I still like it I still
liked it but I didn't like it as much as
I just have a certain Nostalgia for for
that you know what I mean and
says I'm not a real nostalgic person you
know what I mean like I'm willing to
like watch [ __ ] that I saw like a long
time ago
and be like is this still good like am I
still enjoying this you know what I mean
I still I liked the golden child but I
didn't like I used to love it like back
in the 80s I'm like I would watch it
like every single time it was on yeah
but when I saw it again I was like man
this isn't as good as that remember
things changed but I mean well the thing
about it was that some movies that I saw
from back then like I saw him again I'm
like oh this is absolutely still as good
as I remembered but that one was not I
like I didn't I didn't like it as much I
liked it I liked it the demon and [ __ ]
they were trying to make the little
[ __ ] little boy eat the [ __ ]
porridge with all the blood in it yeah I
liked it yeah grandpa says other
characters you actually kind of believe
existed uh Tony Soprano Archie Bunker
yeah Willem Defoe in the lighthouse oh
Willem Dafoe that's another actor I
really really like yeah yeah he's great
Jeffy Hart says I agree with Tom I think
Cruz uh had or has the potential to be
amazing but his management team won't
let him right do you think his acting
limitations could be a Scientology thing
probably uh no what I think it is well
Scientology is part of it grether says
my New Year's Eve resolution for the
world stopped talking about Tom Cruise
this was a long time ago
the Tom Cruise Inc okay and his [ __ ]
support
see him as an industry you know what I
mean as a [ __ ] as a business
they can't take a loss
and they're worried about image
so they make sure he is only in movies
where he's kind of the leading man and
uh
pretty much a
a noble character really is what they're
always trying to be
so so he's going to be limited right
there
yeah right there's a limitation you
never let yourself be morally gray or a
bad guy right I mean you're you're
cutting yourself off from like a
potentially really really interesting
set of roles the closest the closest he
did from Ever playing a bad guy of
course would be collateral
okay
from what from the movies I've seen so
far it was a great movie has he ever
been a straight up villain villain
see even in collateral he was an
admirable but see that's what I'm saying
so that was the thing
now I haven't seen all of his movies so
I don't know has he ever just been like
a straight up villain villain where he
didn't have any redeeming qualities
whatsoever see I'm kind of doubting it
he's always like well he's a hit man but
he's like he's not one of the bad Hitmen
you know what I mean like he is kind of
he's still pretty cool he is very you
know no he is like he just won play like
he wouldn't do like Michael Rooker and
play like yeah and just play like a
scumbag yeah you know what I mean I have
a lot more admiration for actors that
will just go all in and play a scumbag
Tom has never ever play a scumbag they
won't allow him to place a scumbag
I mean even though he's played some
characters I know like that had scumbag
qualities but he also had like good
quality yeah
you know a lot of it and then his his
characters or the the characters he's
playing always seem to have what you
would call in Scientology OT powers
okay they they have the force slightly
uh he's never planned he's never gonna
play a guy who doesn't have OD powers
and he's never gonna play a guy who's a
[ __ ] skin on bag now Ben brings up
Tropic Thunder now he did play a pretty
scumbag character in Tropic Thunder I'd
have to see that again because I haven't
seen it in a long time you would
probably love Tropic Thunder everybody's
tells me to watch it they said I love it
you would love it yeah you would love it
yeah I'll see it I haven't seen it a
long time but you that is absolutely
right up your alley yeah
huh
you know so and he does play I like I
can't remember if he had like redeeming
qualities or not but he was like a
pretty shitty character in that yeah
so
Camp guy said Robert Mitchum was a good
bad guy character yeah it's like I said
I always just feel like and I feel like
a lot of actors like I said actors that
actually really enjoy acting and take
the craft of acting seriously they
always say they want to play bad guys
because bad guys are a lot more
interesting good guys are kind of boring
you know what I mean I mean not
necessarily like good guys but people
that you know are like actual people
that have like different you know facets
and different layers and stuff like that
it sounds like how long we've been uh
doing this show one hour and 32 33.
laughs
yeah Eyes Wide Shut he was uh he had
that I thought he did a great job in
Eyes Wide Shut great Kubrick flick I
want to see it again actually now that
you just mentioned it I love Kubrick's
stuff
um good movie Kubrick trying to tell us
something and it was true he's trying to
tell us you know [ __ ] about those
child island men those guys on the
islands with these children that's what
he's trying to say
um
he must have known about it
and then he goes about up he goes about
telling us about other scams about guys
using their daughters to [ __ ] as a as
a way of blackmailing other men and
weird [ __ ] like that
um Cruz played in it basically an
unlikable guy in that
it's kind of a douche if you ask me he
was a dude he's kind of a stiff but see
I couldn't tell yeah watching that movie
if he was supposed to be a douche or if
that was just his natural Tom
cruiseiness like coming through Tom said
Tom Cruise said he didn't like that
character that that character was I did
not like that character either yeah he
was a jackass he was a jackass so he was
a jerk and he was like very entitled and
he was just kind of like well I'm just
gonna bust my way into this like top
secret party where I wasn't invited and
all this other kind of crap right so
that's what you're supposed to you're
supposed to not like that guy
okay that's good well because like I
said I think that was one of the things
that threw me off about that movie was
because it was Tom Cruise I'm like well
Tom Cruise always kind of comes across
even when he's supposed to be ostensibly
likable he always kind of comes across
as like a
a very cocky [ __ ] to me so it's like
when I was watching that movie I was
like now am I supposed to want to punch
this guy or no well he was worried about
whether or not his [ __ ] wife was
giving the [ __ ] away but then he's
going to these sex parties
well see that's what killed me about it
and she wasn't even given the [ __ ] no
no no no she just said she had like a
fleeting fantasy about it she just
thought about it yeah like I saw this
hot guy yeah and I was just kind of like
oh you know maybe I maybe I'd want to
jump on that dick but she didn't do it
she thought about it for like five
minutes and then she was like that
motherfucker's ABS right and then she's
like oh that's yeah that's cool and then
like it went away and then like she
tells him about it against her and he
goes through this big huge thing and I'm
just like son yeah oh my God what is
your [ __ ] problem and then he goes
out and does stuff actually she didn't
do anything she thought about it no well
[ __ ] for like a minute that that's
why Cruz said that that dude was douche
yeah
what the [ __ ] man so you're gonna go
sneak out on your wife and like go
because
she thought about that dude's ABS so
you're gonna go out [ __ ] these girls
and how does that make any sense
well that was part of that was part of
Kubrick Kubrick knew how to [ __ ]
Kubrick understood he understood the
mindset of the [ __ ] of a mundane
I guess so that's like yeah I mean he
really did kind of like hit hard that
whole like double standard kind of thing
it was a double standard right
because it's like she didn't even have
to do anything and she's just like
talking about I glanced at this guy like
in a hotel it's like she didn't know
that dude she didn't talk to that dude
or not that she's just like oh it'd be
nice to like jump on that dude's dick or
something like that like for a second
yeah and then like he took that as like
lice oh I'm gonna go out and do whatever
the fun I'm gonna go to these big sex
parties and all this other kind of [ __ ]
like I can do whatever I want now yeah
typical don't do that dudes
I was [ __ ] just a couple weeks back
man for a couple couple months back me
and Jim were at the [ __ ] club I'm
[ __ ] at the other end of the bar
getting a drink because it's all crowded
young good dude comes up
offers Jan a [ __ ] drink okay she
turns his ass down every head got big
though I wasn't mean no no no but I just
said well and I already had one and I
didn't want him to get like an idea go
up there and go who what the [ __ ] is
going on here
women have egos too yeah I mean it's
good that they get confirmation from
these young dudes that yeah they're
still trying you're still attractive
Chad this young man thank you you're
still attractive they're coming after
you although to be honest I'm like a
little weirded out because it's like I
don't really that's how it is well I
know that but it's like I don't really I
feel kind of bad you know what I mean I
feel kind of bad because it's like one I
already had a drink like hey I'm not
gonna turn down free alcohol okay but
it's like one I already had a drink it
was like almost full two
um I I don't like that feeling of
entitlement or be or you know now now
you feel like I owe you something yeah
so it's like some that always makes me
like really uncomfortable so I'm always
just kind of like and I hate being put
in that position actually because I
don't like having to be a dick to
somebody I mean unless they're being a
dick to me and then I don't have a
problem at all but if they're like a
nice person because he seemed like a
nice dude it was normal he was just no I
know but it's just like I always feel
bad because now I'm like now I'm in a
position where I just have to be like no
I don't and then sometimes they try to
like convince you it's like no for real
and I'm just like oh [ __ ] please don't
make me like yell at you no he's just
trying to do what it meant do
and of course you know because I'm very
introverted and I don't like putting
being put in positions you know see I
don't get I don't get mad about that
because that kind of affirms like yeah
I'm with a desire of a woman of course
you know what I mean if [ __ ] the
dudes weren't interested then what I'm
not doing my job
you know I mean that's how I'm looking
at it what is what is your job exactly
my job is to [ __ ] you know my job is
to be with a beautiful woman what are
you talking about
they're not if they're gonna be nice I'm
not doing good if they're you know I'm
not doing good if if they're not after
you you know what I mean so that's you
know that's just how it is
well grafter says most people know
buying someone a drink has no strings
attached but not everyone thinks so see
that's what I mean you never know uh no
no this with this dude no he was that's
what I mean and that's he was a young
guy trying to [ __ ] right and it's
like when you could kind of tell like
like I said he wasn't obnoxious he was
really nice actually he was doing what I
was doing yeah but you could tell that
that's kind of what he was doing you
know what I mean he was making the
rounds he was 20 something and that's
what they do at that age yeah so you
know so no I understand but see but the
thing about it though is that and maybe
if you're you know being a woman like in
those kind of situations you actually
never know like if the dude's gonna be
cool about it or if he's gonna uh go off
because I've had that happen too I've
had like you know some guy like will
come up and be like hey can I buy her so
I'm like no you know no thank you I'm
not like rude or anything like that and
then sometimes they'll be like oh you
fat [ __ ] or something like that yeah
like you know what I mean or are you a
dyke or something here's the thing
they'll start with that I've had that
happen too Jin doesn't have to worry
about that anymore though she's in a bar
owned by a friend of ours well I know
that but I'm just saying that it was
[ __ ] twice that motherfucker's size
okay and then there's [ __ ]
dozens of [ __ ] friends all over the
bar that [ __ ] you know I mean that
[ __ ] they've come up with us over the
past 10 years
though he's gonna do anything to you
okay no I know that [ __ ] but I'm
just saying sideways he's gonna get
stomped oh yeah he's gonna get it he's
gonna get [ __ ] stopped all right so
no you were saying if I'm drunk enough
I'll do it yeah if I see her going off
well [ __ ] I got into something uh not
well maybe it wasn't the last time we
were at mannequins at the time before
because one thing I hate
and this happens a lot at mannequins
okay is that you get like all all the
normies in there yeah and like they're
really very obnoxious with their dancing
um in the sense that it's like we're
just gonna take up the whole floor We're
Gonna Knock into people isn't that funny
like look how [ __ ] you know it's it's
like they they just want to like draw
attention to themselves and I will punch
you if you [ __ ] I will punch you
especially if I'm really drunk then I'm
just gonna be like pop you know what I
mean I don't or either that or I'll be
real slick and I'll just be like whoops
and I'll like trip you and you'll fall
on your face yeah I will I will
absolutely do besides [ __ ] talking to
me he slides right
said Jenny you're hot you had to watch
your back top jobs to watch your back
side said he loves your glasses yeah
thank you yeah I got these for a while I
bought those glasses for her I said
Jenny you need to get some big old
[ __ ] big 70s with the little cat eyes
on the end that says that
so all the all the goth girls are
wearing these now [ __ ] it it worked out
of course
just I'm her hip connection
keeping up on on things
with the youth
Camp guys it's poor form to just walk up
and offer to buy a drink it makes you
look weak I yeah I mean I don't really
like I said I don't I'm not gonna I
generally don't want to turn down free
alcohol now if it's coming from somebody
I know then yeah if you want to buy me a
drink okay fine but like I said it's I
have to know you and I have to know that
you don't like expect any [ __ ] out of
that you know what I'm saying Seth says
I love when the guy simply cannot
believe you wouldn't want him yeah he
must be a lesbian they're out there yeah
I've uh oh yeah there's a lot of them
are like that well that's what I mean
like it mannequins isn't too bad because
you know we get a lot of normies in
there who I don't know but like we know
a lot of people there and we know
everybody that works there we know we're
seeing enormous which is we the real
word is mundane's [ __ ] yeah you know
mundane people call them normies
I don't mean that to be a racial slurb
it gets you off
mundane's just regular people okay
you just gotta watch it you know the
average person [ __ ] is okay they can
behave most people are okay right but
they got some people that just don't
know how to [ __ ] act yeah and we had
we had that happen like last time we
were there they just don't know how to
behave they don't have Club etiquette
they don't know how to [ __ ] keep
their eyes opened and to understand to
be able to they can't read the room they
can't read the room to survey the scene
of who's with who they don't understand
it okay
because they're new and they don't have
any connections to the scene they assume
no one else has any connections to that
club
when it's nothing but couples in there
and people that couples that have known
other couples for decades and decades
you know they don't get that
yeah I mean they haven't been around
some of the people that go in there I've
known them for like right 15 years right
and some of them try to hit on these
[ __ ] women who are [ __ ] hot right
but those women
have husbands that are sitting right
over there
and their daughters are older than that
dude and hotter than that dude okay but
they don't see that they're dealing with
a woman who's 40 something late 40s yeah
she looks 24. she's not she's 47. you
know what I mean there's a lot of that
you know yeah we encounter that quite a
bit right because a lot of people think
of well 47 that's an old woman
no
no
[ __ ] we got friends that are [ __ ]
late 40s early 50s you look at them you
think they're in there they're in there
yeah you would never know you'd never
know well I still think that people like
associate maybe the goth look with
somebody that's younger yeah so when you
see somebody that's not very obviously
old like dress Gothic you just assume
that's a younger person right but a lot
of times it's not a lot of times they're
much older than that appear to be a lot
of these dudes are assuming that Jim's
like 30. you know this is that's not the
situation yeah
dude's like 25. you know what I mean and
[ __ ] doesn't understand that Jenny's
fifth 50 that I'm an old [ __ ] yeah you
know
although I feel old some days and I'm
talking to guys and I asked him so how
do you think I am you're 31 I says no
dude 54.
and so oh
you know I'm older than your dad
you know yeah that's what I mean they're
like we're like their parents right yeah
so it's a little weird yeah
I'm not offended it's just weird yeah
let's see
dudes just go to Mexican VIP brothels
where dreams come true yeah it must be
that must be Tom's in Inglorious
Bastards yeah Tom Sykes says senior
citizen discount in a few years I'll be
able to get that probably
right yeah when do you start giving
senior citizen discount 55
sweet I'm going to take advantage of
that five more years I'm gonna get cheap
[ __ ]
can't wait
[Laughter]
tell everybody to get off my lawn
start bringing coffee coupons to
everywhere like counting [ __ ] out with
pennies
[Laughter]
I'm gonna lean into the old lady [ __ ]
I'm gonna lean into it
I'm gonna show them the other gin
okay I gotta well I'm gonna go to the
bathroom you do that
the drink
this is the other gin
the other gen that's that that's
Dimitri's wife
Jen's about 50.
and a lot of these dudes don't know
that that's a
you know you'll have guys in there
[ __ ] come on
trying to get that [ __ ] to [ __ ] Focus
is there going to focus
come on
what the [ __ ]
can't see the face
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] ridiculous
but she's got kids in her [ __ ] 20s
foreign
come on
it won't focus
can you guys see that
there you go there you go
that's the one that's that's a woman in
her 50s
okay
here she comes
couldn't get it to focus real well
thank you sly
oh my gosh look at that little hippo in
there that's it Oh wait we're getting a
wood slice eh
not this it's just like a little
applauding hippo okay I love the
applauding hippo thank you very much
yeah they're saying too close pull back
uh Tom Sykes said I'm sure you could
tell at the end of the day with all the
makeup off their face that they were 50.
um maybe no it depends no well you
messed up my lighting again who's saying
this
Tom psych said that oh yeah yeah no you
don't dude no
there are some people that there we go
there are some people at 50 to me look
like old people I'm out of looking man
you look [ __ ] like in your 60s
there were other people in their 50s
where I can't tell them from a person in
their 30s
you know
in the light no makeup
just can't tell them apart
you know
not everybody ages at the same rate
and uh
just Health has a lot to do with it
I mean we have friends that
were in their 20s just 10 years ago and
you look at them now and they they look
very different and they [ __ ] tell us
that we're vampires you guys don't age
part of it's [ __ ] part of it is
natural and part of it is not natural
because me and Jenny are we're enhanced
slightly because of some of the medic
some of the drugs that we take
let me go get um
Tom's and glorious bastards so where is
the party time what's the plan for New
Year's we are either
we haven't decided we're either gonna go
to mannequins for the blackout fetish
party
that's gonna be a [ __ ] show yeah
um maybe in a good way we don't know
right
um or we're gonna go to Memento Mori at
Barbarella which will be quieter
or like less crowded probably because
that's like not in the middle of
everything so that might be nicer but
I'm not I don't know I'm not really sure
I don't know what we should do because
like I said we went to mannequins on
Halloween and it was fun but holy crap
it was so [ __ ] crowded and I imagine
the crowd that usually goes there like
outside of our crowd um that is total
Amateur hour
so any kind of major drinking holiday
you're gonna have a bad time
and honestly there's not a lot of
parking in downtown Sanford because it's
not huge so Halloween we almost came
back home because we almost couldn't
find a place to park we just like lucked
into a fact we drove down a street and
like somebody happened to be leaving and
so we took their spot but we were just
driving around and driving around so I
kind of feel like that's it's going to
be like accidentally worse like on New
Year's Eve I mean we would have to go
down there super super early if we were
gonna go down there but like I said
Barbarella might be better because
that's in the warehouse District of
Orlando
and there's nothing else around there
you know what I mean like there's no
other clubs there's no other anything
it's just warehouses and they're all
closed so it's almost kind of like more
more like a private party or like one of
those old Raves that they used to do
like out in the middle of nowhere so I
don't know we'll we'll see what kind of
like Vibe we're feeling
and we'll see like who's going where
we're have to gonna like assess we'll
have to do like a poll
of like who's going where
so we have like the most people to hang
out with you know what I mean
Sly says people tell me I look like in
my 40s because I didn't start didn't
start drinking until I was 62 years old
yeah um I honestly didn't start drinking
until I didn't drink
as a teenager really uh I didn't drink
in my 20s I really didn't start drinking
I don't think until I was in my 30s so
it's like I didn't really like [ __ ] up a
lot of [ __ ] when I was young you know
what I mean
Tom's glorious bastard says have you
guys seen the new movie Elvis yes we
actually did a review of it
probably a couple months ago
probably a couple months ago
um yeah it's very good gotta say Elvis
was one sexy [ __ ] I got a man
crush yeah the guy that was in it was
like really really good I can't remember
what his name is right now but yeah he
was great
I'm gonna okay
Tom should dress his baby new year with
a Bane mask
laugh
if I had money I would pay to see that
that would be like [ __ ] hilarious
Camp guy says wheat turnip greens and
Black Eyed Peas on New Year's Day the
greens for money and the peas for coins
yep that's my grandma always she used to
do that every single year
but I didn't I didn't eat it she always
made it
I was like you you guys have fun with
that I'm not eating that [ __ ] maybe
that's why like I never had bad luck or
I always had bad luck like every year
and I never had any money because I
didn't eat the turn of greens
and honestly like until recently when I
was growing up I hated hated Black Eyed
Peas
hated them what Black Eyed Peas oh yeah
because my grandma always made them
because Camp guy was saying like on New
Year she'd always eat black eyed peas
and yeah and I was like yeah my grandma
made that every year and ham and
Cornbread yep
she used to make that every single year
and I wouldn't eat it well I'd eat the
cornbread because cornbread's delicious
but
didn't eat the turnip greens or Black
Eyed Peas I said maybe that's why I've
always been four that's the secret I
didn't eat the good stuff on New Year's
Eve you actually got me into
um there's a lot of [ __ ] I got you black
eyed peas and well actually just green
peas because honestly green peas yeah
just regular peas God I [ __ ] hated
those that was one of my worst like even
the sight or the smell of them like when
I was growing up would just make me want
to vomit
yeah and so for a long time that was one
of my worst like food aversions I got I
didn't have a lot of food aversions but
that was my main one I got a bunch of
hams
and ham bones I'm gonna make some
[ __ ] split pea soup in a bit
and Jenny used to hate [ __ ] green
peas
she's like that was like her the main
one that was my candy just like the
sight of that music on a barf so what I
did was I don't know why I pureed him
into split pea soup where there were no
peas in there just green yeah but see
that used to gross me out as a kid too
because there was baby food like that
um and then I lived in Britain for a
while they have mushy peas they'd always
have like chips fish and chips and I
always thought that was the grossest
[ __ ] ever I gave you that split pea soup
though this is years back you're like oh
this is good yeah what was it it took me
well Isis it to be honest I didn't like
say but
um it took me a really uh
an act of God for me to like take the
first spoonful of that because I was
like really really but when you started
eating them what was it that did I'm not
well because it didn't taste the way I
expected I guess yeah
I don't I'm not really sure I had this
I've lost a lot of food aversions
because I was actually like pretty picky
as a little kid yeah as a little kid the
only thing I couldn't eat was sauerkraut
and then eventually I got to where I
could love that I still don't like it I
love sauerkraut like I'll eat it but
it's not really there's very few things
that I won't eat but I mean there's some
things that I'm just kind of like bad
rather not I'd rather not my mom would
start cooking up that sauerkraut and
that smell would get to be to [ __ ] me up
and I started [ __ ] running from it
crying I used to feel like that I used
to feel like that like when my grandma
was a cat right because you boiled
cabbage because it smells like farts
really I mean let's not lie that's
exactly what it smells like I was like
why are you making this house smell out
farting nobody wants to eat that that's
Nature's way of telling you please don't
eat me
running from the sauerkraut crying no no
what's the problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
but now I [ __ ] love it I still don't
like sausage sauerkraut mustard potatoes
you know and did some German [ __ ] there
I mean you've made a couple of times
you've made like the whole like the
whole
Germany make the whole Germany like the
German potato salad and like sauerkraut
and all that and I've eaten that before
but it's like I would rather just have
the meat and the potatoes I'm not a big
fan of sauerkraut yeah I'll eat most
other things but that's old school
German [ __ ] they probably they probably
don't even eat that anymore
well like I said I eat Mexican food well
yeah like I kind of feel like the you
know since the Advent of the internet
and foodie culture and all that other
kind of stuff like everyone kind of
knows about what everybody else is
eating it's not like back in the old
days where where it was everybody ate
that yeah yeah
[Laughter]
the Germans are all eating Mexican food
now I don't know like I wonder
um you know any of you guys because I
know some of you guys are um British or
like maybe in other parts of Europe I'm
curious as to like what the extent is of
like the Mexican food situation because
I haven't been to the UK since
2009 and even in 2009 like there was in
the bigger city like in London and stuff
there was some Mexican restaurants but
it still wasn't a massive thing because
lit growing up in the United States like
Mexican food is very much a thing yeah
you know what I mean like people people
don't even think of it as like a foreign
Cuisine it's Mexican food it's
everywhere A lot of it isn't foreign
because well that's what I mean your
basic American Mexican food is a is a
version of calmex which is California
Mexican food or Tex-Mex which is Texas
Mexican food because we have Mexicans in
California Texas everything through the
[ __ ] well even
Mexicans didn't move in here they were
here first they were already here yeah
yeah but the the American Empire
expanded into their territories
so America was was America spread
Westward it
it merged with Mexican food
now it has been described
by calmex and Tex-Mex people
that American tacos are Mexican or
California Tacos were emergency tacos
they were tacos made out of emergency
situations they didn't have all of the I
love the idea of an emergency it's an
emergency time they didn't have all of
the Mexican opponents that they needed
so he used American components whatever
they had laying around would you like
throw it in the [ __ ] taco right
because it's an emergency but I got
Mexican friends you know like Khan
konavat Salon he's in the [ __ ]
comment section A lot and [ __ ] when
we're off show we're trading recipes and
trading photographs of [ __ ] Mexican
girls as asses and [ __ ] like that yeah
because you know yeah and then you gotta
look at girls asses it's like taco ass
yeah
my response has got to be like a number
between one and ten of like yes eight
okay okay that's it because you know
Mexican gotta understand you know
[ __ ] uh an American man's opinion of
a Mexican girl's ass but this is normal
growing up in Brazil the same thing
Brazilian guys me and Brazilian guys
looking at girls asses and booties and
rating it and [ __ ] going yeah it's
part of biology okay uh it's it's it's
anyway
Mexican food
is in Mexico American food or excuse me
Mexican American food
is the food that corporations picked up
like Taco Bell and all this [ __ ] and
they brought that [ __ ] worldwide
so if you go into Europe
chances are it's going to be an American
version of Mexican food which is not
quite it's not quite the same thing
because
there's a huge war between Mexicans and
Mexican Americans about what Mexican
food is they're like that is not [ __ ]
Mexican food that's American food
which
yeah I kind of feel like we have the
same situation with like Chinese food
because yeah you like American Chinese
food and Chinese Chinese food are two
completely different things right
but I kind of feel like most people know
that right but I was just wondering
because Ben says Curry is the number one
takeaway food in England and has been
for years yeah I mean
um there I mean honestly they love
Indian food right in England but that
makes sense because they had a life like
Indian immigration where
I kind of feel like when I was over
there and like I said it's been a long
time it's been more than 10 years since
I've been over there so it's like I felt
like I saw a couple of Mexican places in
London but I felt like it wasn't as I
mean in the United States like Mexican
food is like ubiquitous yeah it's
everywhere even though there may be more
than one style of it there is well
that's just like any cuisine
look
if you're in a foreign country
and you want to know about Mexican food
I'm gonna tell you look at Mexican
recipes
on YouTube there's a channel called
cooking con Claudia
c-o-n Kong with Claudia
she can teach you how to cook Mexican
food and it's in English
I use a lot of her recipes and they were
recommended to me by Khan of Aslam down
Tijuana
and she's a cute Mexican girl and
speaking English and she'll tell you how
to make everything that they make
it is [ __ ] better if you have Mexican
food is like really really good too like
not only like good tasting but it's also
really good for like um if you don't
have a lot of money yeah like if you
really want something delicious yeah
that is very very cheap to make yeah
Mexican food is well Indian food is kind
of good for that too but like Mexican
food is really good for that it's gonna
be a little bit more labor intensive
okay you're not really making Mexican
food until you learn how to make a
tortilla
to make a tortilla you're gonna need
some cut you're gonna need [ __ ]
tortilla corn flour which is maseka okay
you mix that with water and you're gonna
make a [ __ ] corn tortilla and you're
gonna cook that and make tortillas and
the difference between a purchased
tortilla and a homemade tortillas it's
night and day
yeah they're really two different
universes you want to [ __ ] I mean the
store-bought ones are they're fine
they're fine but like homemade ones the
homemade ones will be where it's at
and you go you gotta learn how to make
carnitas with little meat meat meaties
little Meats little meaties and that's
made out of like pork butt or pork
shoulder
and it's gonna be spiced the right way
lemon juice or orange juice with a bunch
of [ __ ] spices like cumin seeds and
garlic and salt and oregano and you're
gonna slow cook that or cook it in a
pressure cooker
to make carnitas and then you're gonna
and they have to be cooked several times
because you pre-cook it and then you're
pulling off of that and then you're
putting that on a [ __ ] black skillet
and cooking it again while you're making
a taco and assembling it so
you have to learn how to make
guacamole or avocado sauce
if you can't make if you can't get your
hands on Waka or or or avocado then you
learn how to you gotta learn how to make
uh [ __ ] um Salsa Salsa Casita or
house salsa you know Salsa Fresca fresh
salsa and then there's different kinds
of cheeses that you can use mozzarella
cheese is like the basic but you really
want I gotta hear this little Mexican
shop you want the damn white cheese what
was that stuff called I can um
[ __ ]
um I can't remember it's like string
cheese well we're lucky because we kind
of live out in the in the rural middle
of nowhere but not that far from here is
like a really big like Mexican
restaurant slash grocery store yeah and
anything you need for Mexican food that
you're added in there it's called quesu
or cheese o Waka that's what you want
yeah yeah
it's a [ __ ] white cheese it's kind of
like string cheese
kind of like it's also kind of like
mozzarella
man that shit's good uh it's very
expensive here in Florida
a dollar for dollar I'd probably take
mozzarella we can get that a lot cheaper
but there is a difference in flavor
there is a difference I mean mozzarella
will work yeah in a pinch yeah but
but uh go check out Claudia cooking
concludia she can teach you everything
about Mexican food okay uh dollar for
Dollar Mexican food if I can just put
some good meal on the plate it just does
it's uh home cooking
and it's
Southerners understand it real well it's
very similar to Southern food in its
philosophy
where you take something and you don't
waste anything and you just try to you
just making more and more meals out of
out of things it's like that it's a very
good cuisine
the only thing that comes close to it
dollar for dollar
would be Indian food I was just gonna
say I think Mexican food and Indian food
are is my favorite Cuisines for
making like something that's like
[ __ ] super delicious
out of ingredients that cost like a
dollar yeah you know what I mean they
really know how to like maximize yeah
like those two Cuisines like
specifically like are really really good
at that yeah
Ben says 90 of ethnic fast food places
here Chinese Indian Malaysian Japanese
Mexican Thai whatever are run by
Vietnamese operators it's kind of
interesting where is that at
in I don't know if you know but like in
Orlando we have a little section called
little Vietnam and it's like a little
section of blocks that's all like just a
whole bunch of Vietnamese restaurants
and some of them are good I used to work
down there so I eat at them sometimes
but
um let me see they're talking about
oh the Moscow Slayer yeah we'll have to
like um look into that that's that
killer that they just caught oh okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah look into it
yeah because I don't know all that much
about it I haven't really been following
it because
you know
they're asking me my hypothesis I'm like
uh I don't know I don't have to like
look it up I get so wrapped up in all
the stuff that we're doing like for the
show like what movie are we doing today
or what topic are we doing today that
it's like I don't have a lot of time to
like look into other stuff you know what
I mean so I try to keep up with [ __ ] but
it's hard
you all right yeah okay
we've only been on for two hours yeah
we're not going anywhere I'm good
you want to talk about food some more we
can talk about anything you want to talk
about
what you yeah you uh forgot about you
you uh hit a dead end there hold on
let's see what's good everybody's going
see what we're doing
well where are you did you have any food
to make later or no picture says grits
[Laughter]
was it yesterday or the day before
yesterday day before yesterday it was
day before yesterday well we had some
ham left over from Christmas yeah
so he made some grits grits with cheese
put some cut up ham in there and put
some uh hard-boiled eggs in there yeah
brunch green and real but green yeah Red
Pepper Peppers too out of the garden
yeah put those in there that was good
yeah that was good we hadn't had grits
in a long time actually yeah it's been a
while it had been a while it had been a
while
making me think about all the kind of
stuff I can make
today you made it for lunch you made um
you had a gumbo
no or jump or uh it was no it was it was
jambalaya is no it was it was Cajun 13
bean soup okay all over rice
so similar it had like the sausages yeah
yeah it has sausage in there but it was
uh no it was Cajun 13. you made that
yesterday though because we just we had
a little bit for dinner last night and
it was like hot yeah holy crap I think
even you thought that it was like yeah I
thought it was hot
I thought I thought I was just being a
weenie no the 13 being
package came with a with a with with a
spice package in it and it just said add
spices to the food okay
had I known I probably would only put
about half of those in there
I ate it but I was just kind of I like
had to
um while I was eating it I would eat a
bite and then I like I would put a piece
of ice in my mouth like that you know
then put a piece of ice away yeah
it was it was really really hot yeah it
was good though it was less hot today
it might it got a little bit it mellowed
it mellowed out it was very hot though
right okay I'm hungry though about you
what are you gonna make I don't know you
don't know yet no shut it down cut me
loose and I'll make us something to eat
all right okay yeah you will yeah you
want something to eat yeah I guess make
somebody
see what I got you never did you never
did tell me like much of what you did at
the at the at the Oasis what the Oasis
there wasn't much other than other than
the old lady that you were showing like
your Rick Springfield pictures too yeah
yeah
hahaha that was about it but old ladies
be showing uh Rick Springfield pictures
and look at Jenny
coming up with this [ __ ] no that was
that was about it that was about it
wasn't much going on it wasn't that good
of a date
yeah now a lot of people out nah not
really dead okay so I didn't miss
anything I mean you know it's not really
my singing anyway but no I was mostly
just [ __ ] waiting for dudes to show
up with her bikes you know what I mean
that wasn't really much going on
hmm yeah
this week I get like the week between
Christmas and New Year's yeah is always
kind of like so [ __ ] weird I just
always feel like everybody's just like
me like nobody wants to do anything
everybody spent their money that's what
I mean it's just kind of like and when I
you know when I was working like regular
job or even now and stuff like that it's
like everybody's just kind of like
[ __ ] I don't feel like doing anything
like everybody's worn out from the
holidays everybody's broke from the
holidays and it's just kind of like oh
there's another holiday coming up and I
was like I don't want to deal with
anything until like the new year starts
so it's just kind of like this weird
like purgatorial
like week where everyone's just kind of
like in
stasis or like some holding pattern you
know what I mean it always like strikes
me as that and I kind of feel like that
too to be honest with you
Tom Sykes says uh shut it the [ __ ] down
Jenny shut it the [ __ ] down okay she's
good he's gonna go like get something to
eat all right so hopefully you guys have
a good safe New Year's Eve we're gonna
go out New Year's Eve probably but we'll
see how it goes
and we will probably be back talking
about a movie on Sunday right yeah and
we'll see if I have time we might have
like a new logo and a new intro and all
that other kind of stuff we'll see I'm
gonna try and work on that like tomorrow
okay and we'll see if I got ideas like
I've been coming up with stuff today so
we'll see like I'm gonna do it a little
bit at a time but we'll see how it goes
so it'll be neat it'll be like 2023
we're gonna like because I haven't
changed stuff up in a little while so
we'll see uh so thank you for hanging
out with us this evening on the last
live stream of 2022
and whoops sorry something like popped
up in my face all right so we'll see you
guys again on Sunday afternoon have a
good weekend you guys good night